[Musica]
di voi hanno mai nessuno probabilmente
non è stata una delle migliori
esperienze
infatti secondo alcune ricerche di
mercato vendere una casa
rappresenterebbe uno degli eventi più
stressanti nella vita di una persona
al pari di un divorzio cambiare un
lavoro o la nascita di un figlio
se ci pensate bene infatti ci sono tre
problemi e caratterizzano una
compravendita immobiliare
il primo il tempo ad esempio in italia
ci vogliono circa sette mesi in media
per vendere una casa e questo è un dato
medio quindi ci sono comuni dove questo
caso arriva a 12 o 14 mesi
il secondo il processo per una persona
che vuol vendere casa la compravendita
richiede un impiego di risorse di tempo
molto significativo si devono coordinare
numeri innumerevoli controparti dalle
agenzie immobiliari i notai tecnici
geometri le piattaforme di annunci si
deve gestire tutta la documentazione
prima di andare al rogito del notaio e
magari si devono pure fare delle
attività di adeguamento del proprio
immobile e infine come se non bastasse
si devono accogliere innumerevoli visite
da parte di sconosciuti nella propria
abitazione magari ci vogliono anche 20
visite prima di trovare l'acquirente
finale
il terzo motivo è lo stress vendere una
casa per una persona genera ansia
sostanzialmente perché quella persona
non sa a che prezzo si chiuderà la
trattativa
magari inizialmente era stata fatta una
valutazione per quelli mobili è
totalmente sbagliata quindi sono stati
pure delle revisioni durante il tempo e
hanno generato ulteriore espresse nella
persona e poi non si sa quando si
riceverà la liquidità
ormai la stragrande maggior parte delle
compravendite soggette a mutuo quindi
una personale aveva aspettare anche il
processo di approvazione da parte della
banca per l'acquirente oppure ci
potrebbe essere anche il rischio che
mutano venga approvato per l'acquirente
finale allora
quando alla fine del 2017 ho fondato
casa vo
ci siamo chiesti io i primissimi
dipendenti perché vendere una casa per
una persona non potesse essere semplice
come vendere un titolo in borsa
se uno vuole oggi apre un applicazione
sul proprio telefono e con un semplice
tocco di sostanzialmente chiude la
transazione quindi compra o vende un
titolo in borsa però oggi ci sembra
naturale ma non è non è sempre stato
cosino questa è una foto della borsa
valori del 1800 credo e il termine borsa
deriva dal palazzo ter bears di anversa
dove nel xiv secolo si riunivano tutti i
mercanti d'europa per andare a valutare
le merci ei titoli che scambiavano era
sostanzialmente un luogo fisico dove
avvenivano questi scambi e dove ogni
transazione era soggetta valutazioni
negoziazioni coordinamento di tutte le
controparti coinvolte che magari erano
fisicamente remote e dove il
proprietario del bello della merce era
sostanzialmente soggetto con la stessa
incertezza che oggi caratterizza il
processo di una compravendita
residenziale di un privato è successo ci
sono voluti sostanzialmente sei secoli
perché oggi sia possibile appunto
acquistare o vendere con un semplice
tocco sul proprio smartphone
e questo grazie sostanzialmente a due
fattori il primo è l'avvento dei
cosiddetti dealer che sono diversi dagli
intermediari dealer sono dei soggetti
degli istituti che acquistano un titolo
o un bene da un soggetto per poi
rivenderlo successivamente ad un
soggetto terzo
e questo è stato il primo fattore è il
secondo fattore è stata la tecnologia e
grazie alla tecnologia e siamo riusciti
a ridurre a una frazione di secondo il
tempo di una transazione ea ridurre al
minimo i costi di una transazione se
oggi uno vuole comprare o vendere
ci sono in borsa riesce affatto a farlo
ad un costo sostanzialmente intangibile
rispetto al valore del titolo della
merce sta scambiando e noi con casa vo
abbiamo la vision il sogno di fare lo
stesso per le case nel sud europa
partendo dall'italia
quello che facciamo che ha un servizio
di vendita alternativa del proprio
immobile a chi vuole vendere casa noi
sostanzialmente immediatamente forniamo
un'offerta d'acquisto al privato
impegnandoci noi a voler acquistare
quell'immobile e garantiamo nel giro di
pochi giorni o settimane siamo già dal
notaio li vediamo l'intera cifra
dell'immobile
dopo di che il venditore esce di scena
per lui si conclude il processo
ristrutturiamo l'immobile più o meno
intensivamente in parallelo allori
commercializziamo troviamo l'acquirente
finale e lo vendiamo nuovamente stiamo
sostanzialmente facendo quello che fanno
i dealer per i titoli in borsa e il
tutto supportato da una piattaforma
tecnologica che ci consente da un lato
grazie ad un algoritmo di valutare nel
modo più accurato e più veloce possibile
gli immobili che stiamo transando e
dall'altro di automatizzare e ridurre al
minimo le attività i tempi connesse ad
una compravendita
dalla documentazione alla gestione degli
appuntamenti alla commercializzazione la
ristrutturazione tutte le fasi del
processo
non sappiamo quanto ci vorrà ci sono
voluti sei secoli per la borsa forse ci
vorranno 30 40 50 anni non lo sappiamo
però crediamo fermamente che una persona
debba avere la possibilità di vendere la
propria casa nel modo più veloce e più
snello possibile
questo richiede un esercizio che in
letteratura di gestione aziendale si
chiama categoria design molto
semplicemente significa disegnare una
nuova categoria all'interno di un
mercato tradizionale preesistente che
faccio due esempi semplici e penso che
un meno lasciare tutti se pensiamo al
settore del turismo mini
dell'alberghiero della ricettività erbe
in via creato una categoria
completamente nuova rivoluzionando
quella gara le logiche del settore lo
stesso è accaduto nella mobilità per i
trasporti con l'avvento di huber e
l'esercizio di disegnano nuova categoria
pone ancora di più l'accento sul valore
del capitale umano all'interno di
un'azienda nelle prime fasi e nello
specifico presuppone due cose in termini
di persone il primo è freschezza mentale
apertura il secondo essere completamente
scevri da quelle logiche di pensiero che
da sempre hanno determina hanno
caratterizzato quel determinato settore
che si vuole rivoluzionare e questo è
possibile solo se si inizia questo il
progetto di questo tipo con persone
hanno poca o nessuna esperienza
all'interno di quel settore
ecco questo era l'angolo del coworking
milanese da cui siamo partiti alla fine
del 2017
eravamo come si chiamavano di operatore
tradizionale inizio un gruppo di
ragazzini e e avevamo l'idea e del sogno
di rivoluzionare il modo con cui si
fanno le compravendite residenziali in
italia non avendo però mai comprato
venduto una casa per conto nostro
e questo è stato fondamentale è stata la
cosa più bella è probabilmente il
fattore di successo iniziale per noi e
penso lo sia tuttora onestamente in
generale c'era molto scetticismo e poca
comprensione da parte di
tradizionalmente operava in quel settore
e non capivano né cosa fossimo
esattamente nell'entità del cambiamento
e volevamo portare
vi racconto un aneddoto divertente gli
ormai a milano da circa dieci anni però
sono nato e vissuto a montespertoli è un
paesino vicino a tanto tutti o più o
meno tutti conoscano ogni tanto torno il
fine settimana e lunedì mattina prima di
tornare a milano puntualmente si ferma a
far colazione un balcone o la hbo
mi ricordo ancora quando circa un anno e
mezzo fa erano usciti i primi articoli
sui giornali locali è il proprietario di
san saba complimento è saputo il tuo
figlio aperto un'agenzia immobiliare a
milano
e questo succedeva da abbastanza
frequentemente ma è normale perché
creare una nuova categoria di mercato
gera un'antinomia informativa nei
confronti del consumatore e non ha più
riferimenti no ma cos'è casa vaud è
un'agenzia immobiliare
no perché non facciamo intermediazione
non lavoriamo le agenzia immobiliare è
un fondo immobiliare
no non facciamo raccolta da parte di
fondi e di soggetti terzi per investire
nel settore immobiliare è un costruttore
no neanche prendiamo immobili usati e la
ristrutturazione al massimo va ad agire
sulla redistribuzione interna di
quell'immobile noi siamo un instant
bayern questa etichetta è nata in
america quasi cinque anni fa per
descrivere questa nuova categoria di
mercato è pensata in città come phoenix
dove il modello è partito inizialmente
un immobile su dieci ormai si vende
senza più una visita o al massimo una
visita fisica l'immobile quindi viene
valutato istanteneamente e la
transazione si chiude nel giro di una
settimana più o meno e questo succede
per un immobile su dieci è come se voi
oggi invece di vedere le insegne per
strada dei principali franchise ii 10
insieme biliari lo vedeste più niente
fosse una piattaforma tecnologica dove
ogni persona prima di vendere la casa si
fa fare una valutazione e poi uno su
dieci tendenzialmente lo vendo a questa
piattaforma
quindi potete capire bene l'entità e la
portata del cambiamento e oggi noi
abbiamo raggiunto 200 transazioni
immobiliari abbiamo concluso circa 200
transazioni immobiliari quindi data è
già aumentato rispetto a quello con cui
mi hanno introdotto siamo mai a un rete
di circa 30 40 l'acquisizione al mese
cresciamo in modo esponenziale
abbiamo raccolto oltre 50 milioni di
euro per finanziare da un lato questa
crescita importante quindi stiamo
investendo sulle persone ricerca e
sviluppo tecnologico in marketing per
creare questo novate goria di consumo è
chiaramente un modello di business che
richiede molto capitale per l'acquisto e
la ristrutturazione degli immobili che
trattiamo e siamo arrivati a circa 60
persone
ora con questo mese non sono circa
entrate a settembre una ventina quindi
adesso nella fosse un po più vecchiotto
non le vedete tutti e secondo me delle
volte abbiamo sempre fatto le
riflessioni sul quale è stato il tratto
che ci ha permesso di raggiungere questi
risultati di crescere così velocemente e
un tratto che ci ha contraddistinti
tutti è quella che chiamiamo ambizione
ingenuo cioè quella capacità di spingere
pensiero oltre quello che sembra
possibile e di non farsi condizionare da
quelle persone che tradizionalmente
hanno sempre operato all'interno di
predeterminati schemi mentali e poi
assumendoci dei rischi anche in modo
ingenuo dei rischi che un operatore
tradizionale chiaramente non si potrebbe
mai non si potrebbe mai permettere in
una determinata fase di sviluppo della
sua azienda
una delle cose che mi dà più
soddisfazione fare innovazione assieme a
60 persone con un'età media di 26 anni
in un paese dove il tasso di
disoccupazione giovanile circa il 33 per
cento e dove sembra che non ci sia
nessun investimento dove niente si possa
fare
ecco noi siamo sicuramente il dito
nell'occhio di chi la pensa in questo
modo la nostra storia probabilmente
implica un messaggio per tutti i giovani
e desiderano lanciarsi in un'iniziativa
imprenditoriale a carattere innovativo
nel messaggio è fate il salto nel buio
fatelo bene non ponete limite alla
vostra ambizione e assumetevi rischi
anche in modo ingenuo
questo per voi perché è un'esperienza di
crescita personale e professionale
bellissima e perché l'innovazione credo
fermamente sia un elemento essenziale
nello sviluppo del genere umano
grazie
[Applauso]